bonjour un jour maïté on a des choses
impressionnantes là devant nous amuser
qu'est-ce qu'on va s'amuser qu'est ce
que c'est cd en 10 et c'est énorme
énorme jean-guy alors dites moi manger
manger des anguilles dans la vie
quelquefois qui était quand même
beaucoup beaucoup plus plu ah oui mais
non non non mais il ya plusieurs sortes
langue ils vous avez là qui veulent tout
petit peu people c'était quand même un
petit vermicelles un petit verre qui
devenu sans après
j'étais petit et pee
wee on comprend à pérouse avait languit
l'homme qui gon salon qui est excellent
free c'est délicieux il est normal
et un peu vous avez deux monstres dans
glee qui sonne comme ça et même plus
loin encore et c'est des adultes de
grande taille joli alors elles sont
vivantes là vous croyez oui on le moment
elles dorment bien gentiment est scellé
elles vont souvent les cheptels à vous
croire et c'est aulas l'a pas ce qu'est
ce qu'il va falloir faire eh bien il va
falloir des as sommer et le tuer il
entendu voilà alors fait pour les tuer
je veux être assommé on va voir l'autre
main il faut les 1,6 et d'un taux de
tours voilà il faut exercer tous les
tours bouge pas ma chérie ne bouge pas
ma chérie enregistre ses liens et après
on l'appelle aïe aïe aïe oui oui oui
allez le vietnam a plus rien à ma puce
alors là j'ai pas de chiffres oui vous
allez voir et la peur et mifid
la toile mais parce que vous lui avez
raconté évidemment un la voilà et bien
vous allez voir on va pas se faire comme
ça y'a plus rien à ma biche bien là
là il faut pas être un grain de tenue et
et oui et c'est dix ans il tient votre
chiffre à peu près aucun oui
vous la somme est un petit coup là pour
venir
je crois que ça ne lui suffit même pas
à ma chère tu n'auras pas ma peau
a dit moi c'est vigousse était la
terrible vous avez l'air de vouloir
dormir et
or ces rires ça y est on voit là et bien
là c'est vous qui allez me prendra le
relais veut oui je la connais bien m'a
serré oui et moi je vais prendre le
couteau
voilà dans la tournée comme ça
il va surtout le tour et après ça vous
rappeler ça va être très difficile mais
on va y arriver est arrivé
et à la fin c'est vraiment la mort je
pense qu'ils font oui oui je vois qu'à
la tête la tête vous sauf la tête et moi
d'accord avec des chiffons attaques en
dessous ça y est je la tiens mais il
faut faire la prise c'est dégueulasse et
c'était très facile
et pas du tout que je vais vous met-il
et fait face à la jetée
avec dans les cavités pas allez allez
allez allez allez
oliver
voulait pas d'un coup de couteau
allez messieurs ça vient ça vient ça
vient à l'esprit est là je voudrais fort
là parfait
maléfique huit nageuses de mort à la mi
saison on a eu en fait maintenant nous
allons pouvoir et où il agirait en fait
pas ça tous les jours il faut que damir
aller ça y est je vous débarque tout ça
mais qu'est ce que vous allez faire
maintenant et bien maintenant voilà
tronçonné sa cavale vivre et on va faire
notre bon alors première opération l'a
tronçonné notre en saône et loire lui
couper la tête tout à faire là la coupe
en morceaux
la revoilà ma belle tu ne reverras plus
voilà et puis ensuite dans la vie draps
bien entendu oui et puis rien
c'est superbe vous l'aviez simplement
passant le doigt de dieu
vous êtes débarrassé de votre iphone
un merci la chine s'est mis au travail à
deux c'est beaucoup mieux voilà très
bien on va la vie de celle là non le
ventre n'est pas là il est là
cet enfant tel comme je dis tu souffres
oui enfin c'est plus facile de faire
bifteck
vous est offert par résultat est
tellement bon qu'une fois de temps en
temps il veut se donner la peine de
faire ce genre de choses que vous savez
tout le monde a très bien vu comme vous
le faites là on sait que là on est ont
sonné elle est vide et elle est morte ça
surement plutôt deux fois qu'une et
alors maintenant on va préparer le fond
de l'eau en dessous sous continent de
l'autre qu'est ce qu'il faut a alors là
j'ai mis des oignons rappelons de vire
un peu tendu tout doucement dans de la
graisse de canard voilà toujours pareil
et ensuite bon je vais mettre des
lardons que j'ai déjà coupé voilà mais
l'avant après celle ardent pendant un
petit bout je veux y mettre un petit peu
de fenouil à nous ne mettons pas cela
c'est une nouveauté l'arc j'aime pas
vraiment alors je vais pas mettre
beaucoup et en face et les traditionnels
normalement dans la mal vie leur pose
enfin tout petit peu quoi que c'est
sucré un peu le fruit d'un coupé ça très
bien voilà entré je vous l'enlève
puisque vol en avait suffisamment du
pain et du persil et
le laurier il est là aussi nous de faire
le pays m au petit champignon bien
propre bien joli que vous aller couper
en morceaux voilà la même on retrouve
comme le champignon de paris mais
quelquefois on peut mettre des sceptres
jeu la maison ce n'est pas plus mauvais
que le bien
donné que le meilleur nom après delahaye
de l'appareil
2 gousses d'ail
et les échalotes que vous avez préparé
la france allait remettre aussi un petit
peu
mais on préfère pas une zone en salle on
a mis des bonnes opinions nouveau alors
que se disputent
la fin pour l'art saler poivrer imagine
quand même et après on va rajouter autre
chose et bien sûr alors le sel
le poivre
alors là vous avez préparé quelles sont
alors les cups
epix oui moi je croyais que d'habitude
on les achète dans le commerce sont
réunies la menoua c'est très intéressant
parce qu'on les a en vrai voilà alors
les fameuses quatre épices et quoi ça
sert ses découpes 02 pas beaucoup il
faut par m oui après c'est du gingembre
à la sas forêts ça sent bon ça c'est de
la camair qui est bonne une ampoule non
mais t'es pas beaucoup quand même et
alors là il faut le regretter un petit
peu celle ci c'est landreau fiscal voilà
que l'on gratte avec une petite rade
leur spécialité rap qu'on achète dans le
commerce on la leur de la veste noire
oui nous sommes tous assez bon et
ensuite je vais le couvrir et laisser
mijoter le laisser les autres et tout
seul en attendant
on va faire pendant que ça va me sauter
tout doucement on va faire bouillir du
vin pour notre matelot le limbourg
mérité d'y aller flamber bien sûr je
vais lui mettre le feu
voilà on va la laisser brûler quelques
instants en attendant qu'on va garder
sa vallée froide leur ouïe très bien où
ça sent bon c'est pas bon ça semble
assez joli
et des grands voiliers ça commence à
attacher à tout pour y arriver il faudra
bien afin de faire aurait pas trop vite
parce qu'il faut qu'il voulait quand
même et comme l'oignon qui brûle c'est
pas bon alors là ça va finir de brûler
là j'espère voix la voix la vallée très
bien et les gens qui ont fait ce qu'on
veut nous et wii
ware
va très bien et bien ce qu'elle fait
parce qu'il est maintenant le fer là on
vas y toi la vie de ton va mettre les
morceaux de olivier mois et puis c'est
terminé et ça va surtout se lever il
faut sa crise longtemps une bonne heure
au moins une bonne heure on le voit il
faut que la couleur soit belle il faut
que ce soit bon il faut que ce soit
comme il faut evil 2 et à couvert ou
sous la fesse et saluant le couvert à
couvert voilà et c'est tout et c'est
tout à tout à l'heure c'est pas très
difficile pas du tout le pire c'est de
s'occuper de l'animal au début voyons ça
il nous reste du temps et comme on a de
très très belle envie des grosses qu'est
ce qu'on pourrait faire avec en faire
des brochettes de nuire faut-il l'épaule
et maïté et b non pas possible tant
mieux et relaxer la tornade on est en
dessous de ses tours l'a d'ailleurs la
nageoire voilà on fait de jolis petits
morceaux oui c'est à dire en se basant
la brochette connaît bien sûr si vous
avez des brochettes courte vous faites
des petits morceaux si vous avez des
brochettes longue vous faites des
morceaux un peu un pouvoir et alors on
ne paye pas lié aux vies de pas et on va
en manger toute la tribu sa part
étourneaux voilà on l'avait cloîtré on
en enlève après ouais alors apprend la
brochette animer un poivron au fond on
prend d'anguille et on lance il enfile
et c'est gagné voilà voilà non non mais
un petit peu ou alors parce que ça
paraît quand même oui là après un autre
poivrons rouges encore les couleurs
basques oui dans ce projet parce qu'ils
sont à la fête voyez les anguilles au
pays basque en font un titre issu voilà
à peu du vin
on en mangeait beaucoup donc dans votre
famille
parce que on trouvait ça dans les trous
dans les prés autrefois oui même en
corée oui il ya des prêts ou
lola douvres comme ça reste oui et il ya
les amis en juillet surtout de la voile
avant dans lé président l'a jamais prise
là je n'ai plus qu'à la salle et la fois
vrai et faux saler poivrer assez quand
même non oui pourquoi est ce que vous
n'avez pas mis de ventrèche ou de la rdo
que la ville est très grave c'est par
elle même alors faut pas exagérer non
non non c'est grave mais maintenant
qu'il sait bailly la balle va bien jeter
on n'a plus qu'à faire une jolie braise
et à mettre ses prochaines de 6 ans
mettre les brochettes dessus je n'avais
prépare une mais voilà
il faut une brève très chaude malte est
très douce pourquoi parce que
le langue il est très épaisse oui alors
l épaisse et les très grasse alors si
vous avez une braise très forte elle
brûle et elle n'est pas cuite à
l'intérieur les saisies d'indiquer si
les douces s'appuie tout doucement la
grèce et le fun qui ravive un petit peu
la flamme et puis voilà tout et bien oui
mais si la femme est trop grande sera
pas arranger non plus les anguilles on y
jette du sel ça ne vous aime pas mais ça
les calme et bien maintenant maïté on
pourrait imaginer comme ça qu'on
accélérerait une heure a passé presque
terminé et bien voilà parce que la
matelote accueilli elle a réduit après
une jolie couleur une bonne heure et
demie et puis non brochettes dans guinot
grosse anguille dans la cheminée il leur
a fallu dix ont quoi envers minutes
alors on imagine qu'elles sont restés
vingt minutes que c'est presque puis
résultat c'est qu'elles sont payés oui
que les poivrons sow bien grillées et
tout ça est plutôt avec eux tout est
parfait prêt-à-manger prêt-à-manger 300
signalements ça fait pas un plat très
cher parce que vous me disiez que les
autres partout mais oui pendant toute la
séance de l'année entre des anguilles et
tout le monde chez vous c d attraper ou
est quand même très pauvre on en trouve
toujours des deux tours on trouve toutes
les litres de rouge on l'a il avait dans
votre projet de mettre de
sainte-croix-du-mont du saint-émilion
avait un très cher en tout le monde a
une bouteille de verre pourtant au rouge
et bien je peux vous dire que ça vous a
peut-être paru compliqué mais c'est
comme nous le faisons maïté nous bien ou
mal je n'en sais rien mais si la joie
dans la maison et nous vous en serez ton
tout autant merci au revoir